in the war in Ukraine there's growing
concern that the fight could seriously
damage Europe's largest nuclear power
plant the facility is in Russian
occupied territory Ukraine and Russia
have accused each other of shelling the
plan this comes as more ships carrying
grain leaves Ukraine's black seaports
Charlie dagada is in a Southern
Ukrainian city of Odessa Charlie good
morning
good morning four more cargo ships left
these ports yesterday and other two
vessels set sail today but there's a
backlog of 20 million tons of grain and
Farmers on the front line of putting
their lives on the line to gather this
year's Harvest
hmm
the Chug of War over the country's
grains may have shifted in Ukraine's
favor for now but in addition to
overflowing silos at the Port millions
of tons of grain are piling up at farms
like this north of Odessa
third generation farmer urologist tells
us if the grain deal collapses Seoul is
Farm
we do not have much trust in Russians he
says they can strike the grain ships
with a missile at any moment
he's banking on shipping out this year's
Harvest first it's worth more fresh and
he's got nowhere to store it anyway
this is last year's Harvest mountains of
grain stuck in warehouses across Ukraine
farmers are now harvesting this year's
crops while Russian forces attack Fields
farms and storage facilities
whole Fields turned into inferno's
livelihoods wiped out starving the world
of vital Food Supplies
shelling warehouses and storage
facilities Farmers Under Fire forced to
wear flak jackets as they work the
Ukrainian military reported Russian
shelling in dozens of towns along front
lines in the Southeast hammering nearby
Nikolai with sustained artillery and
missile strikes while the Russian
Emergency Services released images of
damage around the Zappa regia nuclear
power plant after both sides traded
accusations of shelling the compound
again president zielinski called the
renewed shelling Russian nuclear Terror
the nuclear Watchdog the iaea expressed
great concern over the situation and the
U.N Secretary General called it nuclear
suicide calling on inspectors to have
access to the compound for CBS mornings
Charlie dagada in Odessa Ukraine